who or what do you think
god is
how is our conception maybe put another
way of god changed throughout history
we're starting with an easy one lex yep
so what is god well god
is a thought
god is an idea
but it's its reference is to that which
is beyond thinking beyond our ability to
even conceive
um beyond the categories of being and
non-being so how do we talk about that
to talk about it is almost to get it
wrong
right so uh joe campbell famously said
that you know any god that is not
transparent to transcendence is like an
idolatry because it's just a mental
construct
and it can't possibly speak to the
incomprehensible so we use poetic
language we say
the being of beings the um
the infinite
life energy of the universe the the
mystery of transcendence boundless life
unqualified is-ness but it doesn't quite
get to the point i think that if there's
any great insight from mysticism it's
that you and i participate
with god
in a very real way lex friedman here in
austin texas that in the here and now to
touch that eternal principle another way
to refer to god to touch that eternal
principle within ourselves
is to participate with with divinity in
some way um so not an external force but
that divine sense within so there's some
aspect in which god is a part of us so
one it's the thing we can't describe
this represents all of the mystery
around us it's outside our
ability to comprehend and at the same
time it's somehow the thing that's
inside of us
also the ultimate paradox mcfield of
magdeburg 13th century german mystic
maybe the first german mystic
um
says that the the day of her spiritual
awakening was the day that she saw and
knew that she saw god in all things and
all things in god and so we can say this
by the way without apology or
lightweight theology or
vapit speculation or even heresy you
know we can we can talk about this
including within the abrahamic faiths
the mystical core of these faiths all
talk about the encounter of divinity
within that's what i explore in the
immortality key that this notion of
uh techniques
archaic techniques in some cases of
ecstasy that allow that experience of
the eternal principle to actually rise
up in our consciousness
when we're still here as flesh and blood
beings
there's some sense in which our
conception of god though
is conjured up by our own mind
and so aren't we
creating god
like aren't we the gods
that are creating the idea of god
like if if we are
like when we talk about
god
aren't we playing with ideas that are
created by our our mind and thereby
we are the creator not god
this is a very kind of
cyclical question but
in some sense i mean
that
if god is the thing that represents
the mystery all around us
contrasts that with our conception of
god the way we talk about him is more a
creation of our minds it's not the
mystery it's our
uh struggle to comprehend the mystery
and therefore we're creating the god in
terms of the god that we we're talking
about in this conversation or in general
if that makes any sense it makes no
sense whatsoever
but this is this is uh this is the
eternal mystery um
this is why it's so difficult to talk
about and yet it could be the very
center of our beings um
you know the upanishads
speak about us as the creators about us
as gods it's a very different creation
myth but the god of the upanishads
um in this great verse talks about
pouring themselves pouring themselves
into creation
indeed i have become this creation says
god and there's a great line uh verily
he or she who knows this becomes in this
creation
a creator
so
yeah i mean just our ability to engage
in mentation our ability to to think
about this stuff is partly our divine
nature this is what the humanists were
talking about and in the renaissance by
the way um and that it's not so much
learning putting dots together having
arguments with each other over learned
books it's it's a process of unlearning
is what some of the mystical traditions
talk about
unlearning all these thoughts emotions
traumas and experiences that have gone
into the fast construction of our false
self that behind all these layers like
peeling back the onion
is a part of us
that once you can identify that
begins to look a little bit different in
other words it's one thing to
foster a relationship with god it's a
very different thing to identify as god
and i mean that quite literally without
being heretical you can you can find
this
in the mystery traditions
can you expand on this you mean a human
being can
can embody god
that is um textbook incarnational
theology that you can find in any any
christian mystic um but you can find it
in the mystical tradition of islam and
and judaism as well so rumi for example
um the great the great sufi mystic talks
about um if you could
get rid of yourself just get rid of
yourself just once the secret of secrets
would open to you that the face of the
unknown would appear on the perception
of your consciousness
rabbi lawrence kushner a modern-day
contemporary mystic
talks about uh because this stuff does
continue there's a continuity the poetry
here is incredible so well listen listen
to rabbi kushner he says that the
emptying of selfhood
allows the soul to attach to true
reality and in kabulism the true reality
is what's called the divine nothingness
i yin and so i like the adage that
atheists and mystics both essentially
believe in nothing except that the
mystics spell it with a capital n
the divine nothing yeah and then i'll
give you meister eckhart
uh another medieval christian mystic he
says that um if you could not yourself
right the same concept if you could not
yourself
for just an instant indeed i say less
than an instant you would possess all so
again you're seeing the same thing in
sufism
kabbalism christian mysticism the way to
identify with the divine is to peel back
these layers and attempt to discover
pure awareness
if we look at the universe from a
physics perspective or you know i'm a
computer science person so
if the universe is a is a computer
there's some sense that
god
the creator of the universe or just the
computer itself
doesn't know what the heck is going to
happen
it just kind of creates some basic rules
and runs the thing
so there is some element in which
you can conceive of humans or conscious
beings or intelligent beings
as uh
as a tool
that the creator uses to understand
itself himself
do you uh do you think that's
a perspective that uh we could or is
useful to take on god that
is basically
the universe created humans to
understand itself
he doesn't actually know the full thing
he needs the human brains to figure out
the puzzle so that's in contrasting to
the unlearning to getting out of the way
that we've talked about it's more like
no we need the humans to figure out this
puzzle well we have no answers to this
which is why philosophers still have
jobs if they have jobs at all but i mean
there are so the physicists take a look
at this um have you seen the article
that came out i think it was this month
in the journal of cosmology and
astroparticle physics um uh robert lanza
the biocentrism theory the idea that the
universe comes into being through our
observation right the whole the god
equation so not just in quantum
mechanics but in general relativity the
idea that that we make the universe
moment by moment which is kind of
mind-blowing gets into ideas of
simulation
okay so that's how the physicists at
least some of them might look at it you
could also look back to the medieval
christian mystics
meister eckhart once again
says that the i with which i see god is
the same eye
that sees me right so one sight
one knowledge
one love um
another mind-blowing concept but this is
this is why the arts and poetry and
music are so important because although
i love astroparticle physics
it's another to kind of hear this uh the
same message um across time yeah the
simulation thing
i was actually looking this morning at
video games just the statistics on video
games and i saw that the two top video
games in terms of hours played
is fortnite and world of warcraft and i
saw that it's 140 billion hours
billion hours have been played at those
games
um
that's a lot of video games that's well
yeah but that that's very sophisticated
world is being created especially in the
world of warcraft it's a massive online
role-playing game so you have these
characters that are together sort of
creating a world but they in themselves
they're also developing they have all
these items and they're growing like
they're little humans like there's
complicated societies that are formed
they have goals they're striving and so
on
and it's we're creating a universe
within our universe and for now it's a
kind of um
it's a basic sort of constrained version
of our more richer earth-like
civilization but it's conceivable that
you know that
we are this thing on earth is a kind of
video game that somebody else is playing
it's like you could see sort of video
games upon video games being created
that uh and this is something i think a
lot about not from a philosophical
perspective but practically how fun does
this video game have to be for us to let
go of the
silly pursuits in this meat space that
we live in and fully
just stay in wow stay in world of
warcraft stay in the video game
for full time so i think about that from
an engineering perspective like is there
going to be a time when this video game
is actual real life for us and then the
creatures inside the video game
they'll be just borrowing our
consciousness for sort of to ground
themselves will refer to us as the gods
right like won't we become the gods
this conversation is not going how
expected but i think about this a lot
from you know because i love video games
and i wonder
more and more of us especially in covet
times of living in the digital world you
could think about twitter and all those
kinds of things you could do think about
clubhouse people using just voices to
communicate little icons sort of in the
digital space you can see more and more
will be moving in the digital space and
let go of this physical space
and then the the remnants
of the the ancients that created the
video games that nobody centuries from
now will even remember those will be the
gods and then there'll be gods upon gods
being created
this is the kind of stuff i think about
but is that any at all useful to you
to this thought experiment of a
simulation basically the fabric of our
reality how did it come to be what is
running this thing is that useful
or is it ultimately
the project of understanding god
of understanding myth
is the project that centers on the human
on the human mind
for you
we seem to be at the center of this
divine dance which which sounds awfully
anthropocentric
but
um the ancients thought about this too i
mean the concept and sanskrit of lila
that the point behind existence is this
play right it's ultimately playful this
divine dance
it gets awfully complicated in the
gnostic and neoplatonic schools these
chains of being from godhead down to us
right
some invisible right
and we're going to get into terence
mckenna territory later on but we can
start now by talking about discarnate
entities and archons and aliens and
archetypes i mean there is a a world
where terrence mckenna does meet plato
and gnosticism um quite kindly and that
that's in the um this invisible college
right the um
the invisible world uh with which we
seem to have some kind of symbiosis
um that has a higher intent maybe even a
purpose or a plan in mind for us so i
mean these ideas come across when you've
had a heroic dose of mushrooms
they also pop up in the ancient
philosophical literature this idea of
archons who you know
the puppet masters controlling us flesh
and blood beings
um
it's all uh it's all a cosmic dance and
there are no answers to this first who
are the archons the second what is this
world where transformative means plato
do you mean in the space of ideas
or are we talking about some kind of
world that connects all of consciousness
throughout human history i think through
different techniques it is you know i
think a lot about i think gordon watson
is the meeting point of the two so so
gordon watson who i do talk about in the
book uh was this
jp morgan banker turned ethnomycologist
and he's largely credited with the
rediscovery of psilocybin containing
mushrooms
which kind of gave rise to the pop
psychedelic revolution of the 1960s um
he visited maria sabina down in mexico
in his wake when bob dylan led zeppelin
the stones and everybody else
um and the way he describes his
psilocybin experience um is a bit
strange because he thinks of plato right
um and he says that you know whereas our
ordinary reality is kind of this
imperfect view of things uh gordon
watson felt that on mushrooms he was
spying the archetypes and he talks about
plato and he writes about the archetypes
in this famous article that's released
in 1957 in life magazine and so a
well-read
individual from the mid-20th century has
his
premier psychedelic experience and
outcomes plato because what he was
witnessing was so sharp so brilliant so
detailed
in some sense more real than real this
noetic sense that william james talks
about that when you confront something
more real than real these discarnate
entities these images
this uh these visionary motifs you're
tempted
to believe that you've tapped into the
truest nature
and the underlying structure of the
cosmos and that's difficult to escape
from whether you're plato or terence
mckenna or gordon wasson caught in
between
you